okay so these are the 10 commandments of
clueless thou shalt have a robust and
surprising vocabulary faradic means once
in a while it's like painting tape from
far away it's okay but up close it's a
big old room and gesticulate for added
effect whatever sounding sophisticated
will make a big impression you guys talk
like grown-ups thou shall embrace
philanthropy take initiative for causes
close to your heart and give generously
daddy some people lost all their
belongings don't you think that includes
athletic equipment thou shalt harness
the power of negotiation never accept a
first offer so I figure these grades are
just a jumping up point to start
negotiations speak up when you disagree
I have judge do you recall the dates of
these alleged tardies thou shalt
practice the art of seduction show of
how desired you are and flaunt what
you're working with sometimes you have
to show a little skin this reminds guys
would be naked and then they think of
sex expose a little domestic Flair
whenever a boy comes you should always
have something baking even if it's an
epic fail it will probably still be
adorable
oh honey babe thou shalt know driving is
an art form sure there are laws poop
permits do not equal a license but
there's also a lot of room for
individual interpretation and
self-expression - will observe party
etiquette it's essential to survey the
scene upon arrival
Latin for location has some chic dance
moves an understand party limit it is
one thing to spark up a doobie and get
lace to parties but it is quite another
to be fried all day thou shall have
original insults you are snob and a half
you're a virgin who can't drive but
using sold sparingly because you can't
take them back
thou shalt remember fashion is life the
rest is just details make sure you're
coordinated trust in design what the
hell is that a dress says who
Calvin Klein this is an Alya I know what
a bow shall embrace makeovers because
makeovers spawn revolutions Cher's main
thrill in life is a makeover okay it
gives her a sense of control in a world
with chaos
thou shalt believe in love don't lead
sight of your contributions to a
partnership he does dress better than I
do
what would I bring to the relationship
some things are worth waiting for like
sex with Luke Perry you see how picky I
am about my shoes and they only go on my
feet but the main thing about love is
that you love who you love even if there
are stoner or dude with super saggy
pants or even your ex stepbrother love
is what it's all about